Vincent Maisonneuve.
- Ça fait un bon bout, là.
- Guillaume Boutin
doit absolument se trouver
un logement, un endroit pour
vivre avec son fils de 4 ans.
GUILLAUME BOUTIN,
résident de Châteauguay
- À la limite un trois et demie.
Je peux faire ma chambre dans
le salon et laisser la chambre
à mon petit garçon si
c'est juste ça qu'on a.
- Si Guillaume ne trouve pas
un logement convenable,
il risque de perdre la garde
de son enfant.
- Ce qui va arriver, bien
je vais juste devoir perdre
la garde de mon fils
une semaine sur deux.
- Mais à Châteauguay, trouver
un trois et demie abordable
est devenu presque impossible.
CHANTAL HURTUBISE,
résidente de Châteauguay
- Un studio, c'est rendu à 935
par mois ici, à Châteauguay,
là t'sais. C'est rendu fou!
- Faute de logement,
Chantal Hurtubise doit, elle,
aller vivre avec son fils.
Benoît Dagenais risque,
lui, de perdre son logement :
le propriétaire veut tout
démolir pour faire des condos.
BENOÎT DAGENAIS,
résident de Châteauguay
- Le nouveau propriétaire,
il fait tout pour essayer
d'évincer le monde.
Dernièrement, il a enlevé
la laveuse, sécheuse, ça fait
qu'on ne peut plus se laver.
- Ils sont victimes de la crise
du logement. À Châteauguay,
le pourcentage d'appartements
disponibles a fondu :
de 1,1 à 0,7 % en 2020.
Dans les banlieues de Montréal,
le taux d'inoccupation est
à peine de 1 %. Les appartements
libres se trouvent souvent
dans les nouvelles constructions
trop chères, inaccessibles.
- C'est comme pas trouvable.
À des prix abordables,
il n'y en a pas.
- De plus, la hausse de loyer
enregistrée en 2020 est la plus
forte depuis près de 20 ans.
- C'est vraiment dur d'arriver
quand tu dis que tu es
monoparental. C'est un stress
qui est assez dur à gérer
sur les épaules.
- Ils s'appauvrissent...
- Les comités de logements
s'inquiètent : ils reçoivent
les appels de locataires qui
doivent maintenant choisir
entre manger ou payer le loyer.
BERTRAND LOISELLE, dg, Office
municipal habitation Châteauguay
- C'est des gens qui
travaillent, une majorité
de femmes, mais il y a
des gens qui travaillent,
40 000-45 000 $ par année.
- On s'attend à un 1er juillet
difficile.
- Montréal est en train
de devenir le prochain Toronto,
le prochain Vancouver.
- Le 28 mars, des dizaines
de personnes ont fait la file
à Verdun dans l'espoir de louer
un quatre et demie à 975 $.
MAXIME ROY-ALLARD, associations
de locataires du Québec
- On voit des files d'attente
déjà sur les réseaux sociaux.
Et souvent, malheureusement,
les locataires vont même
renchérir pour avoir le logement
et ça va défavoriser les gens
à faible revenu.
- Tout ce que les trois
espèrent, c'est de trouver d'ici
juillet un logement convenable.
- Il n'y a quasiment rien
d'abordable ici, à Châteauguay.
- Signe d'un besoin criant pour
de nouveaux logements sociaux.
Ici Vincent Maisonneuve,
Radio-Canada, Châteauguay.